of cardiovascular disease kidney disease
and chronic lung disease like COPD death
rates from cancer are significantly
elevated especially for lung cancer
we've seen evidence for higher rates of
birth defects and for babies born at low
birth weight the difference in total
mortality equates to about 1,200 excess
deaths every year in Mt our areas
controlling for other risks 1,200 excess
deaths every year not only our death
rates higher but they increase as levels
of mining go up in a dose-response
manner next we started to conduct
community door-to-door health surveys we
surveyed people living within a few
miles of MTR versus similar rural
communities without mine survey results
show higher levels of personal and
family illness self-reported health
status is poorer and illness symptoms
across a broad spectrum are more common
these studies are only associational we
all know the correlation does not prove
causation these studies did not include
data on the actual environmental
conditions in mining communities so we
started to collect and report on that we
found that violations of public drinking
water standards are seven times more
common in MTR areas versus non mining
areas we collected air samples and found
that particulate matter is elevated in
mining communities especially in the
ultrafine range the dust and mining
communities contains a complex mixture
but includes high levels of silica a
known lung carcinogen and potentially
harmful organic compounds we use the
dust in laboratory experiments and found
that it induced cardiovascular
dysfunction in rats the dust also
promoted the development of lung cancer
in human in vitro lung cells this is
just a quick summary of some of our
studies the coal industry does not like
what we have to say neither does the
government in coal country just like the
tobacco industry paid for research to
defend the safety of smoking so the coal
industry has tried to do the same by
paying people to write papers claiming
that MTR is safe lawyers have sent me
harassing demands under the Freedom of
Information Act eventually denied by the
courts I've been attacked at public
testimony at a congressional hearing by
a congressman with ties to the energy
industry one governor has publicly
declared that he refuses to read the
research and after a meeting with a
member of Congress in which I
specifically shared my research I later
heard that representatives say they knew
nothing about it I worked with
scientists at the US Geological Survey
on environmental sampling for more than
two years and just as they were starting
to publish their findings they were
suddenly instruct
to by their superiors to stop work on
this project in August of this year the
National Academies of Sciences was
suddenly instructed by the federal
government to stop their independent
review of the public health consequences
of surface mining these actions are
politically motivated in my view but
there is opposition from researchers to
at conferences or meetings they express
skepticism okay we're all taught as
scientists to be skeptical they ask what
about this possible explanation have you
considered that alternative
interpretation they wonder there must be
some confounder that we missed some
other variable we haven't accounted for
an in vitro study what does that prove a
rat study how do we know the same
effects would be found in people maybe
so technically you have to acknowledge
that they could be right but you know
maybe these health problems are not the
result of some unmeasured confound maybe
they result from blowing up mountains
over people's heads
there can always be doubt if doubt is
what you seek because we can never do
that defining experiment any next study
must always be associational so perhaps
you can understand why I've started to
wonder how much evidence is in doff I've
published over 30 papers on this topic
so far along with my co-authors other
researchers have added to the evidence
yet government doesn't want to listen
and the industry says it's only
correlational they say Appalachian self
lifestyle issues as though it had never
occurred to us to control for smoking or
obesity or poverty or education or
health insurance we controlled for all
of those and more there comes a point
where we don't need more research where
we can't ask people to be unwilling
research subjects so we can do the next
study as scientists we follow the data
wherever it goes but sometimes data can
only take us so far and we have to
decide as thinking feeling human beings
what it means and when it is time to act
I think that is true not only for MTR
but for other situations where evidence
is strong and concerning but imperfect
and when failing to act if you're wrong
means people's lives it may seem strange
that there is any controversy over the
health effects of mountaintop removal
mining but somehow this subject has
wound up in a scientific and political
Twilight Zone alongside the debate over
climate change or the argument years ago
about whether or not smoking caused
cancer in this Twilight Zone much of the
data seems to point to one conclusion
with the economics or the politics or
the prevailing public view insists on
the opposite conclusion when your
scientist and you think you have a valid
insight where the health of entire
populations is at stake but you find
yourself trapped in this twilight zone
of denial and disbelief what is your
moral and ethical obligation obviously
scientists are responsible for telling
the truth as they see it based on
evidence simply stated we have an
obligation to stand up for the data
it can be extremely frustrating to wait
around for public opinion or political
consensus to catch up to the scientific
understanding but the more controversial
the subject and the more frustrating the
debate the more critical it is for
scientists to preserve our objectivity
and our reputation for integrity because
integrity is the coin of the realm in
scientific and public policy debate in
the long run our reputation for
integrity is the most powerful tool that
we have even more powerful than the data
itself without an acknowledged integrity
on the part of scientists no amount of
data will ever convince people to
believe painful or difficult truths but
when we cultivate and guard our
reputation for integrity when we
patiently stand up for the data and keep
doing the studies and keep calmly
bringing the results to the public
that's when we have our greatest impact
eventually scientific truth does and
will win out how many lives will be lost
while we wait too many already
but prevail we will
[Applause]
[Music]